TODD KERPELMAN: Hello,
and welcome back
to the second half
of our in-depth guide
to Saved Games using
Google Play game services.
Yes, that's right.
I said second half.
This is the second part
of a two-part series.
If you haven't watched part
one yet, you really should.
Otherwise, this video isn't
going to make any sense.
Go on.
It's OK.
I'll wait.
[HUMMING] OK.
Ready?
Let's go.
So here's where we move into
black diamond difficulty.
So put on your safety
goggles, if you have them.
It's going to get kind of rough,
but I think you can handle it.
You seem pretty sharp.
Dealing with saved
game conflicts
is a situation you're
going to run into rarely,
but it can happen-- particularly
in multi-device households.
And when it does,
you're going to need
to make sure you
do the right thing.
So when you load a
snapshot from the cloud,
it comes with what you
can think of as a version
number, or perhaps a tag.
And this tag identifies
the latest version
of your saved game on the
cloud that our servers
agree is legit.
We sometimes refer to
this as the base version.
Now, you can't alter
this tag or even view it.
It is hidden from you.
But when you save the game
back to Google servers using
commit and close, this
old tag gets sent back
to the cloud along with the
newer version of your snapshot.
Now, when Google servers
receive this snapshot,
they check and see--
is this tag the same
as what it's recorded
as the last base
version of your snapshot?
If so, then it knows that nobody
else has gone ahead and messed
with your saved game in
between the time that you first
opened it and when
you're committing it now.
And if that's the case--
and 90% of the time,
it will be-- your
saved game is updated
and the tag is changed to
reflect the new base version.
So now, remember
earlier when I said
that as soon as you submit
a snapshot, it's closed
and you have to
reopen it again if you
want to do anything with it?
Well, one of things
you're doing when
you reopen this
newly-submitted snapshot
is getting this newest version
of the tag from our servers.
So now, let's go back to
our earlier example here.
And I'm going to go ahead
and introduce a conflict
by adding a second device.
And they're both going to open
this version of my saved game,
which we have tagged as version
A. Now on my first device,
I'm going to go ahead
and make a change.
Let's spend 80 gold here and
get myself a better sword.
And now, I'm going to save
this came back to the cloud.
Google servers are going to
look at the tag passed along
with this snapshot and
confirm that-- yes, it
does match the last base version
tag it had recorded earlier.
Everything looks good.
So my server accepts
this new snapshot,
re-tags it as
version B. And if I
were to reopen this saved
game on this first device,
it would know that it's now
working off of this version B.
But let's not do that.
Instead, let's go
to my second device.
Remember, this device
had last opened
version saved game A. Right?
Well, with that saved game,
I'm going to spend my gold
and buy a helmet instead.
And now, I can save this
version to the cloud, too.
Now, the servers are going to
see that this snapshot is based
on version A, but it also knows
that version B is the latest
base version on the
cloud, so it's not
going to be happy here.
But here's the thing
you might not expect.
It's not going to
reject the saved game.
It's just going to make a
note that something is funny,
and it's going to save
this newest saved game--
we'll call it version
A*-- alongside version B.
Why do this, by the way?
Why not just reject a
conflicting snapshot
when you're trying to save it?
Well, there are few reasons.
One is that this approach tends
to better handle the situation
where a user is trying
to save and load
the game while the
device is offline.
Another reason is
that Android devices,
through some clever
caching of network calls,
might not actually save
your game on the network
while your application
is running.
It might do it a
little bit later
when your application
is in the background.
And if you want to do
something like ask the user how
to resolve these
two saved games,
you really can only do that when
your application is running--
which generally
happens when you're
trying to open the
snapshot instead.
So point being this
conflict doesn't
get resolved until
the user actually
tries to open their
last saved game.
And at this point, the server
says-- oh, hey wait a minute.
I have this version B,
which is the last saved base
version I've declared legit.
But I've also got
this A* version now.
What do you want to do here?
Well, what do you want to do?
What you actually decide
to do depends a little bit
on your platform, and
is kind of up to you.
On iOS, you have a number
of options, one of which
is to let the
library figure it out
for you by declaring a
snapshot merge policy.
If you're to go with GPG
snapshot policy BaseWins,
you're basically
telling the library
to always accept the latest
base version of the snapshot
that the server has accepted
and throw away any conflicts.
So in this case,
version B would win.
If you go with snapshot
policy RemoteWins,
you would accept the
conflict version instead.
In this case that's A*.
And if you're saying to
yourself-- wait, that's crazy.
Why would I ever use
the conflict version?
Remember that, in
our example anyway,
A* is actually the
most recent saved game.
So this method could make sense.
But frankly, I think
both of these strategies
are pretty blunt instruments
without a lot of nuance.
One that I like better
is snapshot policy
LongestPlaytime.
Here, you're asking
the library to look
at the Playtime metadata of
each of these two snapshots,
and pick the
snapshot where you've
recorded that the user
has played the longest.
This could be a smart
way to handle conflicts,
particularly if you're trying
to resolve two conflicts where
one of the saved games is
one where the user has just
played on a plane
for four hours.
Right?
You don't want to lose those
four hours of game play.
Note, however, that this is
all relying on the time played
metadata that is being generated
by you, the game developer.
So it's only as good
as the data you put in.
And then finally, there's
GPG snapshot policy Manual.
In this case, you're given
both snapshots, which you're
allowed to open and
read fully, and then you
can decide exactly how
to proceed-- either
by picking one of
these two snapshots,
or by creating a brand
new snapshot entirely.
In some cases, if you're
doing the manual merge--
in spite of the name
manual, you might actually
be able to merge these two saved
snapshots automatically using
your own games logic.
This works best in games
where the stats tend
to be ones you can
kind of always union
together in a-- hey, let's
just take the highest or lowest
number scenario.
For example, if I have a
game, maybe a puzzle game
where the only
thing I'm recording
are the high scores
and the number of stars
are in the various levels.
My game could probably merge
these two saves automatically,
just using some
simple-- you know what?
We'll take the level with the
highest score kinds of rules.
And this would work out nicely.
In many other cases, though,
such as our example where
the user has purchased a helmet
in one situation and a sword
in the other, I'm not quite sure
how we could merge these two
programmatically--
unless there was a sword
you wore on your
head or something.
But that would be dumb.
So the best scenario
here might simply
be to bring up a
dialog box, and ask
the user which saved
game they want to keep.
Remember, at this point you have
access to the snapshot metadata
as well as the actual
game data, if you want.
So you could populate
this dialogue
with whatever information
your game needs
to make sense to your user.
How ever you do it, once you
pick the version to commit,
this will be saved
back up to the server.
The server will update
this snapshot to version C,
and then it will close it.
Which means-- yes,
that's right-- you
will need to reopen
it again to proceed.
Now, on the Android
side of things,
your choices are a
little bit more limited.
You have no fancy automatic
merge policies or anything.
You basically just have to
pick one of these two snapshots
to move forward
with and that's it.
Now, to help you do this, you
can retrieve both snapshots
within the code.
What the code refers
to here as the snapshot
is the base
snapshot-- where we've
been calling version
B in our example.
And what the code refers to here
as the conflicting snapshot is
what we've been calling
version A* in our example.
And you can recreate
most of those iOS
merge policies with just
a few lines of code.
For instance, we
can always choose
to use the base snapshot.
We could always use the
remote version or the conflict
snapshot.
Or we could always
take the snapshot
with a long display time.
And if you wanted to go
with-- hey, let's show a user
a dialog box with
both saved versions,
ask which one they
want to move forward
with-- you could
totally do that, too.
I just didn't include
the code here.
The only tricky
part will be if we
want to do a manual merge,
where the new snapshot is
a fancy combination of
the two existing ones.
So remember on Android,
you have to just pick
one of these two snapshots
to move forward with.
So what we need to do is
pick one of our snapshots,
save that up as our new save.
Then we could
immediately reopen it,
apply all the changes
we want to turn it
into our fancy
auto merged option.
And then send it up
and commit it again.
And in case you're
curious, this is actually
what the iOS version of the
library does behind the scenes
if you resolve a conflict
with the third snapshot.
It just kind of takes
care of this work for you,
because it's helpful like that.
On the C++ side, you have
a mix of the two libraries.
We do let you pick from a number
of auto-resolve strategies
like we do on iOS.
But if you want to
manually resolve
two conflicting
snapshots with a third,
you're first going to have
to pick one, commit it, then
reopen it, apply
the new changes,
commit it again like you would
do in the Android Java SDK.
Either way, once you have
resolved and committed
your new snapshot,
you should now
have the confidence to reopen
your saved game, knowing
that everything is
right with the world.
Right?
Well, kind of.
In some rare situations,
you might end up in cases
where you have more than one
conflict version sitting out
there on the cloud.
Typically, this happens when
a player is playing their game
on three or more
devices at once.
Rare, definitely.
But it can happen.
Now in these situations, when
you ask to open a snapshot,
you're given the base version
and a conflict version
to resolve-- just like normal.
And just like normal, you
send a resolved version
back up to the server,
the tag is updated,
and then the snapshot is closed.
Well, our game still wants
to use this snapshot.
So it's going to ask
the server to open it.
And that's when the server
tells us-- oh hey, wait.
You actually need to resolve
this new base snapshot
with his other version I've
also had hanging around.
But that's no problem for us.
Right?
We're still just
resolving two snapshots.
This is all the same logic
we've been applying before.
So we simply resolve
this pair of snapshots,
commit the correct version
back to the cloud where
it once again gets closed, and
then we can finally reopen it.
And there was much rejoicing.
Now in general, this
whole idea of having
more than one conflict at
once shouldn't throw you off
too much.
After all, we're
really just reapplying
a lot of the same logic
we've already written.
I think the area where it
can get a little tricky is
if you're an Android,
Java, or C++ developer
and you're waiting to apply
your fancy custom merge snapshot
on top of an existing snapshot
you've just committed.
You're probably expecting to
get a single snapshot back
after your previous
commit and reopen.
But instead, you get back two,
which might confuse your game.
So what you do at this
point depends a little
on your game's logic,
what's in your fancy combo
snapshot, what's in this
new remote snapshot.
But again, it's really
just an extension of code
you've probably already written.
You just need to be aware
that this situation can
happen and code defensively.
All right.
That was a lot of
detail, but I'm
hoping at this point you have a
better understanding of what's
going on underneath the hood
when you start implementing
saved games for your game.
Don't worry if any of this
seemed confusing for you.
We have sample code and apps
and guides for you to look at.
And of course, you can always
re-watch this video anytime you
want.
If I were you, I'd
bookmark this video
and then watch it again
when you're actually
trying to implement this
stuff, because probably
some of these edge cases will
make a little more sense.
So once again, thank you
very much for watching.
Feel free to follow me on G+
for serious work-related stuff
and Twitter for mostly
dumb, jokey stuff.
And otherwise, I will see
you back here in YouTube land
at some point in
the near future.
Later, skaters.
Do people still say
that these days?
Seacrest out.
You know what?
I'll just see you soon.
Bye.